hey we're ready alright hey what's going
on it's bill burr and it's time for the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcast and I don't know
I've just been getting a bunch of guests
lately it's time for another special one
and I got another legend legend here I
got the one and only Stephen Perkins
from Jane's Addiction hi Bill Porter for
Pires infectious grooves yeah and your
latest project the think experience
which we will be getting into first off
thank you so much for doing this I've
been a huge fan you've already been
talking and what happens when you write
before you do a podcast it's like dude
just save that try and save that yes
yeah say nothing just let it flow let
the levee break yes when the mic is on
yes so we were talking about basically
the influence of the internet and how
good these these kids are at playing now
but how it's like almost like they all
grew up in the same town absolutely yeah
because everyone could just kind of go
on YouTube and if there's some sick kid
in Minnesota you didn't have to live
there to see him you just put it on and
you watch it and then his influence goes
into where you are and then it's so
widespread so quickly
yeah and there was such a fine romantic
feeling to find a drummer or a record
and fall in love with it and learn how
to plate it no one else knew what you
were working on right you're home alone
it could have been a Coltrane it could
have been Van Halen or I'd have been
both at the same time you know and try
to kind of fuse this hybrid of yourself
alone and the romance of a drum stick
and the rhythm how did you how did you
count like about lay your style like
like blew my mind when I first heard you
I missed the first few Jane's albums
because I was I was you know neck deep
in and hair metal and all that and when
ritual came out he's just like that was
the first time I really heard somebody
with that kind of music just the sound
of that and just all the snare just
placement and all that it just it just
wasn't that approach yeah of like all
right to and fours the snare and then
I'm gonna do some syncopated [ __ ] and
absolutely you know the bass does this
and I'm gonna follow it with my foot and
you just had you it was completely it
was like
was upside down like how did you arrive
at that well I was I think the great
drummers have great musicians around
them and that brings the the competition
in the jam room brings better
performances out of each other so I was
ultra aware of technique and chops but I
knew that really wasn't my forte I
didn't want to be a fast lightning
drummer and I really find a place for
that and the music I loved my early love
was jazz Buddy Rich Gene Krupa Elvin
Jones but no one in Los Angeles played
trumpet saxophone even piano right no
one even played bass everyone played
guitar so then what are you gonna do
you're gonna bite into rock and roll but
that's swung reward from the Sabbath
Bonham and then I started to check out
what the pocket of Motown meant and how
that influenced Ringo and Charlie and
Ginger Baker and they were playing these
Motown beats but surrounded by great
songwriters right and so this this
fusion this hybrid of jazz swinging and
the flash of rock and roll and then I
kind of hit a ceiling
I was bored I didn't know what other
record to buy Genesis Rush and I ever
bought everything then I said you know I
found through the Beatles probably
Indian tabla rhythms and that opened the
door to African rhythms which was Fela
Kuti in Babatunde Olatunji okay deep no
idea these records were just as
important as the Abbey Road record I try
to make that impression on myself
let those records become part of how
important the rhythm can be not just
these great songs that you grew up with
listen to new rhythms and so those
rhythms started to infuse my creative
side and then I joined the marching band
in you know high school and I said
everyone charge yeah and everyone it was
competitive one first chair and everyone
was showing what they had the flash so
that it could be bad for your playing
creatively but it's good for your
endurance and your confidence so how did
you so how did you when will you mature
enough when you went in there to see
that this isn't what it's about where
it's like I would compare that in
I've done a little bit of acting work
and and I've few very rarely but a few
times I've gotten into a scene with
somebody and it's the silliest sounds
they get in like I'm gonna out act you
yeah hey we're doing this together let's
you know let's let's work together yeah
they get in there like I'm gonna out
create you it's a there's a tennis match
it's going on but you can't always ace
the guy because there's no match you
want a rally right so you do want a once
in a while just you know slam it in pink
right but you can't slam it every time
let's play let's rally let's laugh let's
yeah I'm Yoona Kate and I think growing
up in Navarro at 15 on it was my love
affair with you know guitar and drums I
didn't know much about bass and I that
rhythm section yet cuz no one played
bass so I always wanted to match the
game I always heard that if you play
bass you could get into like 20 bands
immediately nobody wanted up gives
either drums or guitar dying if I'm
going you know right so but I think when
the band Jane's actually kind of to
become aware of our what was important
was the lyrics and the phrasing and he's
not gonna sing like this hair metal
thing were you singing it four times and
then you sing the next thing four times
it's not gonna rhyme it doesn't rhyme he
says something once and then we react
and then he says something three times
and then he says [ __ ] and then
you punch it behind them and you know
and then so it's a poem with song and
then you know so I think we started to
become ultra aware of how it's an
emotional performance it's real estate
where are you gonna place yourself and
we're gonna get out of the way of
dududududududu you know were you gonna
where you're gonna put your plant and
almost like a monopoly game you go over
and over then you buy boardwalk and then
you put a house on it then you put a
hotel on it you make your event more
worthy when you guys like when you guys
were going in that direction cuz it
means so much of it is you know you want
to make it I mean you don't want to be
homeless you know and what you guys were
doing was so different
despite when I listen to you know uh you
know a lot of your influences
the stuff that those guys that I was
listening through them the metal years
we're listening to when you start to
make that departure of like like this
does not sound like what they're what
you know that big thing what they're
looking for like what are you looking
for a man what's this what was going on
85 the strip was coming to an end motley
rat poison it was already ending then
they'd all been signed and it was
repetitive redundant derivative of each
other
Jane's Addiction would go downtown and
there was X and the Minutemen the Chili
Peppers and fishbone and they weren't
successful as far as getting signed to a
major they kind of hit a ceiling the
rock rock ceiling flag was there you
know fear
it was Circle Jerks it was [ __ ]
fantastic but they weren't gonna get any
bigger
I remember X got a song in the Charlie
Sheen movie the baseball movie and I was
like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah X got a song
in a movie there I get he said Punk
Rocky the ceiling so there was that
moment where metal was done punk rock
post-punk so in your world metal was
done in 85 yeah it's already done it was
gone in my world it then as a player to
create it right as a is trying to turn
the key a little and change I didn't
want to be Tommy Lee anymore you know
there was a moment you watched like
because like say you know he was still a
kid so MTV was so huge to our generation
and and you know this scene is over yeah
and and right as you're saying it's over
MTV is just blowing yelling it after the
next level and to the point and when
they would do like the top 10 and it was
like other than like a Paula Abdul and a
Janet Jackson Michael Jackson like they
they could break in George Michael those
people but the rest of it was all pretty
much hair metal yeah videos is not not
civil or pedestrian but safe in our
opinion and completely produced in just
the Machine so what would you watch was
there some what was there a mtv out
there that you were watching or we would
go dig out at which I was you know Eric
and Perry which were almost 10 years old
of the mean in a Dave
they would help us realize the
importance of Joy Division and Bauhaus
and new order and echo and Suzy do you
know I'm just discovering Joy Division
names like most 40 years later that kind
of simple storytelling yeah cuz me and
Navarro were about van Hill and we
wanted to show off they wanted to tell a
story like those guys and cinematic set
a scene and just tell the let the lyrics
speak and of course mean they were still
18 but now we can play watch this right
and that's what the world needed the
metal that's what LA needed it went
global but it was the end of metal and a
punk you know I've been the chilies and
fishbone had records out and our very
first tunes before ritual dare I say
influenced LA funk idiots rule the pigs
in Zen right doodoo right it was Charlie
Peck could have been with the Chili
Peppers show or a fishbone show and then
we started to find our storytelling and
art and I think our best moment back
then was then she did on ritual when the
lyric like I'm saying the lyric doesn't
go for times and the music doesn't go
three times behind it
it's just that second side he had album
I learned how to meditate I swear to God
I used to put it on to lift off yeah I
wouldn't put anything I would put it and
I was really it was like the first time
in my life I was realizing that I was
[ __ ] up I look like Ron Howard my
family looked like the Brady Bunch
we went to church every week and I
thought hey you know I got this all fun
I was [ __ ] you know I went to work I
was a good worker and all that and it
wasn't until that way and it's that
weird thing I was writing around 21 22
and that's right when you're supposed to
be done with college you're supposed to
know what you want you're on your way to
your dream or whatever I put everything
else behind you man yeah and I felt I
was just sort of like floating like what
the [ __ ] like that whole part of my life
is done College just went by I'm still a
freshman basically now what yeah that
the [ __ ] am i doing
and I don't know that's my issue started
coming up so well the the ritual record
even though was the end of the band was
the this what you're hearing is us on
tour and shaving all the parts and
playing them live and becoming an
emotional organism
yeah that's the documentation of what we
sounded like and it was if we had a
great manager he would have said take a
year off I see a future we had a good
manager just that you guys had a breakup
a breakup well he wondered what was now
we didn't give it to him so we didn't
have any guidance but right
in fact just came immediately I was in
Hawaii those guys showed up
Robert and Trey you know arbitrary hero
and Mike mirror they're going on tour
with Ozzy in two weeks I'm in a new band
so I didn't even think it was the wrong
choice to break up but I write you why
with something so beautiful and colorful
just call quits no take a break and
maybe you know like any hot relationship
maybe take a break and then maybe see if
it's is the worthy but we didn't have
any yeah a little say have a date night
and they see I'm still like each other I
mean I am so happy how the the porno for
Pyro's sound became something that was
different and we were able to grow and
we didn't I love that change and I love
the the second album yeah that's that's
the one I was a Tahitian yeah God's
earth station god I love that out that
that making that record was using all
the money Warner's gave us to travel
write songs and then use just a little
bit of money to record it I remember
being all excited to watch Larry Sanders
because you guys were on and you put way
you go away yeah yeah we had it all set
up to do pets and then we got up there
like that's gonna be a bore let's do me
how I was a little more you know a
little charge yeah but the the band
itself was was based on when I was
saying earlier that that rhythm and
phrasing of Perry and I wanted to bring
we didn't want to try to get a guitar
soloist like we had in Jane's right
greatest all right so Peter was more of
a songwriter on acoustic guitar
12-string mm-hmm and we rep songs and
with bongos around the camp yeah I want
to say you hate you you had like bongo
six where you would normally have like
rack Tom's because we wrote the tunes
campfire style with bongos and acoustic
guitarist when we went in the studio
those sounds and frequencies needed to
be there so I started to incorporate
this hand drumming writing style into
the drum kit and make a hybrid drum set
so I'm not gonna rely on beats so when
you recorded that did you play with
sticks Oh were you playing with your
hands on hot rods and sticks good
question you know the hot rods are the
kind of splintered drumstick that oh
yeah that quieter right yeah oh yeah and
they kind of you know you can get into
it still but you don't have the quite
the attack and the articulation a little
bit of brass spread but I the approach
because the bass player Martin was from
Holland and he grew up with music I
couldn't reference any Sabbath tune or
enemies up like you know there's upland
to me you know he grew up in Holly
couldn't say that made it quite
interesting you know as far as a rhythm
section we had nothing to kind of fall
back on so it was all very fresh that's
also interesting that someone could live
in a part of the world that they hadn't
heard of that's kind of sort of hidden
everybody's like hard drive it wasn't
important like in America or Britain or
the world thank you yeah that's central
so right now you that you think you're
doing right now is think experience
that's right and this is like this is
this really sounds cool so this is in LA
of course all the cool [ __ ] seems to
happen here especially when I'm on the
road yeah just one night one miss it yes
when you're in West Virginia it's wisdom
art Park yeah this is a great experience
what we're doing is the the saxophonist
from Pink Floyd and Supertramp in toto
Scott page mayhem and hooked up many
years ago and we've always thought
wouldn't it be great to do Pink Floyd
music in our own way Norwood from
fishbone the bass player Kenny Olson the
guitar player from Kid Rock we all were
kind of hanging out on this Pink Floyd
state of mind the art dome wisdom opened
up downtown and they were looking to
fill the days sometimes they've got a
spin class sometimes they've got a you
know a sound bath but it's always with
these cool visuals so we brought the
band in there and then you basically can
have either a folding seat a beanbag or
a futon bed and the visuals above you it
feels like you're if you are a situation
without the mask so even the band member
is experiencing what the audience is oh
so you're laying down so you look up at
the Dome so it's like wraparound
exactly so from Asus I'm so good okay
helpful shows coming up you gotta go
there's other domes there that you can
trip out on before the show and then the
big dome homes about 500 people and we
play about an hour and a half of all
floyd music with about 11 musicians that
come and go different singers you can
look at the band but why everyone's
tripping and owing and hawing at the
events are you looking I'm freaking out
looking up and I've always wanted back
in the day what it was like not to be
the cast member but the audience member
during my gigs especially James in porno
right and [ __ ] was going on what's it
like in there I really am I'm just this
we're seeing all the same thing don't
you find out once once you've been like
it took me a while but I'm about 27
years in now you'll get don't seasoned
at this point and one of my favorite
things to do is to actually walk into
some place big or small where there's
gonna be the show and there's nothing on
like I don't have to go to work school
and I get to sit there and in watch
comedy or watch a band
what's your game experience yeah I love
it yeah I look that is my fuel my fodder
to play more I love a big show even
though sometimes musically you're
disconnected and the Faro's went over
there and you know Perry's hanging on a
rope right there's no visual moment but
it's also some guy bungee jumping in in
a ferris wheel and you're playing
Mountain sonic this is what are they
thinking I love that so I gotta get that
experience I get to be a an audience
member what is that like when you're on
your way up and it's like the first
places you're playing it's almost the
guys in your bands are almost hitting
your cymbals and slamming that time and
then all of a sudden it's just like oh
hey we finally in a place where there's
a little bit of wrong yeah I don't have
to play like this I can actually have my
kit you know what's drew well what we
try to think that and when that gets big
we tell the text please set us up close
as much as possible even though we need
to be spread for the people way out
there because once you start losing that
that intimate connection with the band
the music does change it's kind of like
being in a phone call in a room that's
quiet you're gonna know everybody
everything every word you're thinking
but if the room is loud and noisy you're
going oh
Hey Dude what yeah yeah oh hey come on
you know that's kind of how the Big
Show's are you're like right
I'm with the guitar player then doesn't
notice something else is going on right
never caused you concern like you know
cuz you always see our hair all like the
amy had four people four different
personalities absolutely at one point
you're just playing and you're like
there's my best friend way the [ __ ] over
there standing in front of a [ __ ] fan
he hasn't looked at me the host show
what are we doing yeah who are we what
is this what is it where's the band and
somebody like crowd surfing and it which
is that's the weirdest thing about music
because then it becomes the height and
but then there's that that that
disconnect yeah I mean I got to think
about you two and the Chili's Metallica
there's this connection they have with
each other that is it it seems to be
very well threaded and tight you know
and they even they even stand close to
each other on stage or they go satellite
stage small little stage off the big one
right to show that unit and to feel that
unit yeah because I almost would feel
like you guys would have to you know
when you get as big as like that with
the band that you would almost have to
schedule together time so you don't lose
what got you there well one thing's
great about always with chains we have a
backstage Jam room and that is a smaller
instrument it's a small amp small kit
little PA and we go back there and play
our favorites plus the tunes maybe to
warm up maybe tunes that will be on
stage that night possibly not maybe a
friend will come and sing with us those
moments Brian are the the moments
remember of 1986 we wrote the tunes on
Santa Monica and vine those early days
we shared a rehearsal place Bullitt boys
fishbone GNR and Jane's and after you
rehearse you put your gear in the corner
and then you bring it back the next day
and I remember you know the Bullitt boys
got a record deal all of a sudden they
had nuclear oh [ __ ] yeah Benji no I got
big this ship moved out they got their
own room you know but you can see
progress that's possible no panic thing
like as a comic you start looking
well that guys he started two weeks
after I did his move
he's up there like I must be doing
something wrong well you were so you
actually sharing this space with people
who are playing the music that people
were saying this is it and you still had
that that thing what did the other guys
like Gina or bullet boys were they
listening to what you were doing I'm
tight with Jimmy Deanna the drummer from
the boys a Bullitt boys and he said he
was recognizing what was happening he
was not only feeling the the sound was
becoming redundant there that it was
happening what's next but also the the
precision and the the Technic the
technical plane but I was being lost in
that type of metal music and so we were
trying to bring back our love of Rush
you know Genesis yes you know there was
like whoa listen to what these cats are
playing even though there's a story we
need to tell we're from Hollywood and
somes gonna reflect the mirror the
lyrics of the mirror you know I was
thinking that was saying nobody mind the
other night like you know everybody like
ragging on discos like a big thing
everybody's like the worst [ __ ] music
ever I will say the heavy metal ballad
are some of the worst songs there's a
few good one scorpions just they [ __ ]
everybody I mean this corpse did one big
one lady lady something about you know
the Berlin Wall I can't recall but I
couldn't never was home sweet home which
that's not one of the worst ones but
there are some out there the the bands
that became derivative derivative
derivative of a Motley Crue and yeah
yeah and then they that was they had to
do that now another Keith Moon they said
Keith when did you stop destroying the
drums yeah we it somehow stopped notice
but they stopped versus you know and he
said when it was in the setlist a song
number seven you know destroy the drums
you had to do it they were done your
drum kit here oh my god a 24-inch bass
drum head with nothing shocking artwork
all right we got to take a picture of
India after what so everybody can say
you thought you'd you know you would
love it especially because you love art
music and you play drums there it is
that thing's been on the drumhead
and on the drums on tour but we never
poke a hole in it we get the mic mounted
on the inside
dude I can't take this you actually know
it's a gift it's a gift to you cuz you
know there's no one up in my drum room
dude like this you got it man what you
do for music and art and I was uh I
don't know if you've seen my act lately
I don't know everyone all of at the
point why it was a good direction like
my act is basically like a heavy metal
ballad and I'm sending it inspiring
other comics to go into a different
direction well my advice to anybody
trying to be a drummer or a musician of
course its technique but don't look for
that pat on the back because it's a bore
you want to piss people off my actual
goal is a drummer is to think of my
three favorite artists there are big
ones
severa Dali because he can paint like
Rembrandt but he doesn't he puts a
[ __ ] rooster come out of the head
that's a it looks real you look closely
it's broken right and then there's MC
Escher with the black duck and the white
duck and the rhythms that just continue
the patterns
that's a drumming pattern in an art
though this is way beyond me and then
there's [ __ ] he spent his whole life
like all of us trying to become he's
used as a brush right and I wanted to be
bottom and then he said he threw the
paint and that's what I thought that's
what do I do when they give me a rock
riff I'm gonna do Babatunde Olatunji I
hate when I go to museums they make me
feel dumb I'm just like I don't get what
everybody's doing but my wife is
gradually trying to get me to be a
little more
well the rhythm is so visual and of
course even our bodies whatever your
digestive rhythm is or your sleep rhythm
your say whatever it is we all have a
rhythm and it just feel right what are
you what are you what are you thinking
when you're playing because you always
have like the biggest smile and it's
like you like even if I didn't play
drums I'd be watching you I'd get guys
having the time of his life
I'm that is the I can't do wrong of
course I can drop the stick or pull off
something the ego can strike you if you
think too much like you got it
right but I can't do wrong as far as I
remember seeing Gene Krupa play drums in
a movie and they showed a guy a
conservative couple he was tapping his
hand in the wife's life uh-huh but they
went to her foot she was tapping her
foot right
that's what drums make me feel like I
cannot lose I'm gonna make people feel
good and life [ __ ] sucks everything
sucks out of the world the news the [ __ ]
what is good is like my kid my wife and
the deer arms yeah and I there's
something fun I remember my friends came
by and I bought a cowbell and I learned
how to play beautiful girl or dance the
night away and Hailey and was like you
know this is exciting it's hitting a
home run for my friends or strangers but
it's it is I got you know I got a
compliment here as far as like the fact
that your whole career
you've always been going towards the art
thing and then somehow it pays off which
is very rare because usually when you go
that route it's painful yeah you're on
the you're on the futon train is usually
where you're at but you you always in
and then when you arrived with Jane's
and then you still were able to go back
to be like now this this feels good
let's let's put the bongos in here let's
do that which was the what nobody was
doing that and what I've experienced
this in in my career where I've gotten
something and then I think of my next
move and my next moves thinking well I'm
here I got to try to stay here I'll go
to that next thing and it's like a you
know a two-week or a two-month hangover
absolutely rush of that thing and you
got to be like we're not wait a minute
why did I yeah what was the reason I got
into this business what did I want to do
so then it always goes back to going
down to the club's trying out a new bid
having a making another comic laughs
absolutely now come come to you gonna do
this something there and then feet and
then drive it home you know did a guest
spot made no [ __ ] money driving home
excited going and then you're thinking
and you're talking to yourself and
people looking at your red lights and
you don't give a [ __ ] our night I'm
gonna go down that's the organic fuel
that I still get I love those drum
events and competition
even though the gospel chops have
invaded but you see everybody must have
rehearsed for the last two months yes
even see the pros that have a 40-minute
performance they yeah you can tell you
can tell if you I mean I would think cuz
those kids that's such a huge shot that
Guitar Center thing yeah yeah I kind of
put it to sleep now but you're right it
was big yeah it helped no I mean I still
follow those like a couple two or three
drummers that I became huge fans I'm
watching their bands and stuff and but
it's good for this it's good for the the
scene it's good for drummers yeah I
though scum petitions like you know it
makes pros and amateurs tune up practice
more practice more that's it I mean I I
try to ask if I remember when I get with
somebody of your talent level so the big
thing you're always chasing no matter
what you're doing is kind of getting
into a zone what's like you're not even
thinking and it's just flowing through
you I mean do you have a way of like if
you feeling like I'm in my head and I'm
thinking about and now I'm hitting the
bass drum enough but do you have any
mental exercise that you do to a ste get
out of your [ __ ] head your zero you're
in New Jersey right now look at that
person over there
take them and like do you have any
tricks and to get you out of the worst
artistic space which is sitting between
your [ __ ] ears absolute thinking what
are you doing there is so many ways as a
drummer I can sit and practice and I'm
alone a lot and there's a lot of alone
time and a lot of my musician friends
have a different schedule and a lot of a
lot of my non musician friends have a
job what am I gonna do in my day oh yeah
I don't want to be faster I just want to
be more alert and be able to pull things
off that I'm thinking with the technique
but there is the time I'm sitting at the
drum kit and I'm like this is a hundred
percent me this is so boring right do a
180 what exactly don't exactly what you
wouldn't play go against your instinct
and force it over and over and see what
happens
yeah and so I have to force myself to
it's you know get away from the
endurance and the technique and the
speed and the flow what's what's gonna
zap me creatively how the heck am I
gonna wake up creatively and come up
with something new
is it putting a bongo in front of me
that would help but that's not gonna do
it I've got to hit the thing how do you
do hit it on tour you're on tour you're
40 [ __ ] dates in you want to go home
you miss your wife and kid and you're
you know how lights go down crowds going
crazy and you're thinking like out Jesus
I would love to go back and take a
[ __ ] nap what do you do then I'm a
complete believer in waking up and
exploring cities towns people the best
sandwich shop the best record shop the
fountain where the punks hang out and
then bring that to the gig even feed it
to the singer they got a fountain down
on 3rd I was at the fountain that's a
turn-on for everybody I love it and I
and I put that into my plane and I tried
to okay why am I here I only play for 75
minutes this is a whole day away from
home or whatever you know I'm missing
and so I do try to fuel it with the I'm
[ __ ] lucky I'm out of town I'm good
tonight let's go enjoy all right I as a
drummer the recognition you don't get
much of it you walk around town I don't
have anybody bothered me I don't know if
that would be an issue I can imagine if
you don't want to be recognized and you
want that world to get out there it
could be a bummer but if I'm really
famous like you know I always wish I
always wish they had that thing from
Star Trek be at home with your wife and
kid and kiss tomorrow and I'm going to
work and then they just you just big
beam beam you to Toronto or something I
mean how many times I want to clone to
send them off to do the gig yeah and
that's why I like it that's that's
always a scary thought because then I
sit there going who the [ __ ] am I to be
not you know enjoying this right now but
then it's like oh that well that's what
makes human beings move forward is you
get bored exactly we cannot just be
there and go this is perfect I'm gonna
ride over and over you know what I do is
I just I go out and I try and just walk
out and not say anything for my act this
is I get myself out of my head and then
if that's not happening even when I go
into my joke what I start to do is I
just try to tag it with different lines
and bla bla bla bla it don't be like the
music equipment be improving whatever
like musical phrase it is and let's blow
that out it's usually take
90-second now it's gonna take two
minutes and ten seconds but it's just
the fact in those last 40 seconds that
it's something that I hadn't said before
even if it sucks even if I'm eating [ __ ]
it's just like oh I'm bombing in
Columbus Ohio right now these people
don't feel like they're getting their
money's worth and then that gets the
adrenaline going so I learned over the
years because I used to not know how to
get out of that and I would spend weeks
or possibly like months and then you get
into like writer's block and I had to
like figure out like how my brain worked
like it works in a very straight line
where like if how to produce yourself
well if I like if I thought about a show
I said three things that I liked and if
I said one that I said early in the show
and then one of the middle and one the
end if the first one I thought about was
in the middle that's where the tape
starts and everything before it gets a
race that's like all right
I don't know what the [ __ ] that is but
that's how my brain works so I have to
I've kind of learned like I don't tape
shows and when I say something and I'm
trying to remember I can't I just I let
it go and Michael that's that's how it
was said I learned that from watching
you guys what was just like hey that's
how the song came out that night that's
the Phil I played that's the thing the
guy's saying you don't have and
everything isn't so [ __ ] fresh it's
not precious and there's also a sense of
humor to it and that's what me and
Navarro and Perry playing the Jane song
so many times with different bass
players we honor the Duff McKagan
and we had and flee and we kind of play
with the arrangement pair you might just
not sing the verse and dance around and
play it's playful and you have to know
it's just you know there's that so
serious bet it's a song but if you're in
the moment that makes it fun and I'll do
something to like make my tech laugh or
for novaro
or will do something backstage prior to
the show van Halen riff and then Dave
will pull it out during the gig and look
at me
that's [ __ ] so cool kind of that's so
cool he's a powerful force that no
people are enjoying it at the same time
there's an inner insight show within the
show yeah that is so [ __ ] cool
hey what are the dates of this this the
first weekend of April in the last
weekend of April at the wisdom Art Park
all right so the first two weekends in a
because I'm going on I'm actually going
to buy tickets before
first weekend in last weekend oh fourth
Friday and Saturday all right so I have
to go to the first weekend because I'm
out of town the last weekend could and
I'm gonna [ __ ] get these tickets
before this thing hits because I want to
go see that I want to be [ __ ] laying
on my back listen at all yeah it's a
next-level experience and I'm going with
the bean bag - can I request that yeah
I'll make sure you have the bag
I had my nine-year-old come and he had
brought like three or four friends and
they were the other rooms got a VR mask
and one room is made of mirrors and
light and and they were just exploring
everything right and that's so cool
because
now the my music means more than just
he's a drummer they can realize and and
his friends that it's an experience I'm
just a slice of it but I want them to
share this new technology yeah because
it's there and you know we can't ignore
it and it's the AI is here but I want to
use it as entertainment but of course
there's other ways that you're cool that
you play drums
he loves it man and that's awesome
teenagers oh my god dad he's dying being
a rock star is your time oh that's so
cool well I know what else did I want to
talk about here all you got are you uh
what do I got down here mm I wanted to
talk to you about the when did you start
playing barefoot this is what I'm going
deep on out let's go to people who
aren't like drummers are listening like
what the got home from school 1213 shoes
and socks off that and then play drums
till about 5 or 6 so I think that's just
the natural taking the shoes and socks
off at home and I play heels up and I
played with the balls of my foot and my
toes and I move up and down the pedal so
there's no comfort zone with the for the
shoe on right I get cramped my toe is
going with like a you know a snail in
there it's like it's not working right
but there is something to say about the
the feeling of an extra weight of a shoe
and I definitely get a different sound
when I have a shoe on and maybe there's
a little more beef behind it I was gonna
ask you if like you're at a club Oh
Stephen say hey come in and sit in you
don't say hang on a second so mr. Rogers
and take off your shoes and socks there
it's awful no don't
yeah I'll use what they guide but if
when I get comfortable behind my kid I'd
prefer to be just in a pair of shorts
nothing else and play do you still have
the kit that you played on ritual these
they'll have its yeah what kind of drunk
it wasn't that wasn't my 1980 or 79
Ludwig that was a loud wail and then on
ritual while that would that during
ritual we used some of my brand new DW
kit as well which was just weeks old but
there was a tour that we just finished
using the same drums over and over so
you have that feeling this is funny when
Jane's Addiction got our first 10k we go
let's go buy a new gear
Navarro played marshals you ain't got
Mesa Boogie bass player played ampeg you
got Trace Elliot I had cracked Zildjian
so I went and got Paiste we went to
rehearsal sounded horrible where was our
sound it just we just bought a bunch of
new gear just put it in the corner it
was a waste of money we've got our old
[ __ ] back
oh no cuz that was how we sounded we
needed yeah we need to go buy gather
yeah he was like longing for this other
stuff when you already had it we had
what we needed man and I've never just
put all this [ __ ] in the corner while
there was 10k you know what if you also
did a project with one of the players
from other strokes right that's right
Nicolai the bass player and now I have a
bass we have a band called summer moon
and we just did it boom maybe about 15
30 shows opening for Danny Harrison and
it's such a cool community of young
thoughtful musicians creative people
that are hungry to change and try new
ideas on stage backstage in this in the
studio is that a is that a new project
that you were working with like the
album's coming out we did an EP about
about a year ago and there's another EP
coming right now yeah cuz that band The
Strokes was a band that I was like I was
like officially like old because I was
freaking out and I was just like I don't
know who anybody is good kid so what is
the band I was looking at him going like
oh my god I'm like almost like 15 12 15
years older than them and but that's
another thing like I have to go back all
the music that I missed when I was
growing up I had to go back and start
listening to that and then there was the
[ __ ] that I missed in the nineties
specially hip-hop and all that stuff for
stuff that I missed and then now I'm
kind of getting into the 2
thousands mm-hmm and just like just
someone like 20 years too late for those
guys so I I don't know there's so much
[ __ ] that to try and listen to but you
know what I loved at the end of the 80s
early 90s was the sound of the drummer
he had something to say he had Primus
and Soundgarden and tool Pearl Jam and
every drummer had something different
than the other and I think the metal
days you're talking about every drummer
wanted to beat Ely and the you know they
just it wasn't happening but it was a
chance now to be yourself and things
change again it comes in waves you know
that creative flow from the rhythm
section have you seen that Motley Crue
movie yet the girl oh man I can't wait
oh it's so good it's it's so like it's
just it's perfect Motley Crue it's just
awesome ridiculous just total Andrew
yeah cuz somebody from the LA Times gave
one of them [ __ ] going like you know
because they showed like all the
groupies that they were banging and
everything great thing and they were
just like just totalized the time yeah I
think it was Tommy he was just like well
I mean it happened I mean do you want us
to like rewrite history what are we
doing here and the story we're telling
the story yeah it was a really yeah it
was my plastic Motley Crue and it was
dark but Indiana overall it was like fun
yeah it was just and you walked out like
dude what the [ __ ] was that like classic
motley show I just I can't say enough
good things about I always [ __ ] up that
expression it's just [ __ ] awesome but
I loved it I loved it
well I got to play with Tommy we had
methods mayhem double drummer and we sat
right next to each other and I took the
floor timeout and that's where his
hi-hat was that's how close Wow and then
he's saying and play guitar while I
drummed and then he joined me and the
meter I mean I did the rehearsals were
the highlights because he had two hours
of me and him the band four hours and
then they would split he's like Perkins
being you going all night it's T lead
yeah the drummer yeah it was just I was
just looking is badass me yes and I was
just listening to that album that the
one who's just called Motley Crue
where they had that that other set right
no dude that album
so [ __ ] underrated there's like if
first of all they put out an hour you
can see what they were doing sigh God we
got a new singer we got to go hard it's
I think it's Tommy's best drumming and
Mike's fire Mick's best [ __ ] riffs
and that singer was just it was it
wasn't was uh was incredible and I was
listening I put it on I was at the gym
it's like an hour long was kind of
perfect and I was like well I slept on
this album I I knew hooligan solid I was
just being a stupid 80s kids like no
Vince Neil I'm not gonna give this a
[ __ ] chance like that yeah but it's
it's for any motley fans out there don't
sleep on that album obviously all the
other ones everybody knows about so
alright well dude I can't yeah I don't
know man I can't believe I'm sitting
here talking to you and this this I'm
gonna cherish or the head oh my god this
thing is I'm gonna yeah that's going
right on see right on the wall my little
drum area just became ten times cooler
and thank you so much for all the
[ __ ] great music thanks Bill and
being a real artist and always going for
something different cuz I love
everything you do and I'm gonna see the
first weekend in April alright Stephen
Perkins everybody check them out Pink
Floyd at the wisdom Art Park here in LA
and and that's it met everybody
there'll be a little bit of music here
and then another half hour of greatest
hits from the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
have a great weekend all right a couple
of reads here alright it's butcher
blocks everybody butcher blocks bit your
butcher block butcher box [ __ ] this
munch this month my god
butcher box is offering I said this
munch is offering finely ground beef
that's clean and delicious and is taken
from the most flavorful sections of the
animal the beef consists of trimmings
from the sirloin and chunk Oh Chuck
sorry which makes it so versatile it
cooks fast so it's perfect for quick
weeknight dinners right now new members
will get two pounds of this delicious
ground beef for free and every box for
the life of your subscription this was
butcher box's most popular offer last
year and they're bringing it back for a
limited time only cook with the peace of
mind of knowing you are eating healthy
high-quality meat each box comes with
lead
at least 8 to 11 pounds of meats which
is enough for 24 individual sized meals
unless your gluttonous and then is
probably like 5 you can choose from 5
different box types all beef beef and
chicken beef and pork mix box custom box
that lets you choose your own cuts my
favorite cut is of course you all know
my favorite meat is e the heritage breed
pork most delicious pork chop I've ever
had it's it's early in the morning I
don't know why I can't [ __ ] talk for
$20 off your first box and two pounds of
free ground beef in every box for the
life of your subscription go to butcher
box comm slash burrow or and to enter
the promo code bar that's butcher box
com slash bar or enter promo code / hey
look who it is is [ __ ] my bookie over
here brackets first round upsets the
final for March Madness is here and it's
time to bet with the best at night
bookie would you rather sit at your
office desk or call out sick and binge
on NCAA Tournament games and junk food
like that's even a choice come on
sometimes it feels good to be bad
especially when it's someone you trust
we're gonna mess with someone you trust
and if you're looking for a place to get
in on all the action you can trust my
bookie they've been in business for
years then they're growing like wildfire
the best part is they pay out fast so
when you call that 12 or 5 that 12 over
5 upset this year make sure to celebrate
you'll be pocketing cold hard cash March
Madness is the most exciting
action-packed sporting event of the year
year even grandmothers fill out a
bracket place your bets with my bookie
now before you miss out my bookie will
match your deposit with a 50% bonus use
promo code Barbie you are are to
activate the order visit my bookie dot
AG today you play you when you get paid
only at my bookie calm or you lose you
lose your job and you're out there
blowin somebody at a bus station okay
just just playing devil's advocate its
frame bridge everyone if you've been
listening to this show you've heard me
talk about frame bridge they make it
super easy and affordable to frame your
favorite things seeking a frame
baseball season starts right framing the
strike zone there from art prints and
posters to travel photos sitting on your
phone here's how it works just go to
frame bridge and upload your photo or
they'll send you packaging to safely
mail in your physical pieces preview
your item online in any frame style
choose your favorite or get free
recommendations from their talented
designers instead of hundreds you'll pay
at a framing store their prices start at
just $39 and all shipping is free plus
my listeners will get 15% off their
first order of frame bridge comm when
they use my code Burpee you are our get
started
freight now to get started frame your
photos or send the perfect gift for
weddings birthdays and special gifts go
to frame bridge calm and use the promo
code BRR you'll save an additional 15%
off your first order just go to frame
bridge comm slash dot promo code wait
frame bridge comm promo code birth [ __ ]
frame [ __ ] calm promo code bar all
right it's quip one of the most
important things we do for our health
everyday is brushing our teeth god damn
right it is death comes from the mouth
[ __ ] bacteria goes into your hot and
you next thing you know you flick your
face plant da spaghetti x' like that
fetch [ __ ] seven right over those
SpaghettiOs anyways yet most of us don't
do it properly grip is the best electric
toothbrush created by dentists and
designers people brush too hard and some
electric toothbrushes are too abrasive a
built-in two-minute timer plus every 30
seconds to remind you when to switch
sides you dope
helping LP it's so easy even a [ __ ] kid
brushes teeth health got helping guy to
a full and even clean why D clutters
your sink or cabinets and makes
traveling with an electric toothbrush
easier equipped doesn't require a clunky
charger and runs for three months on one
charge I'm getting one of these brush
heads are automatically delivered on a
dentist recommended schedule every three
months for just five bucks
why three out of four of us use bristles
that are old worn-out and ineffective
quip is the one was one of the first
electric toothbrushes accepted by the
American
Dental Association and as thousands of
verified five-star reviews why do I love
quip well I don't have one but the fact
that I only have to charge it once every
three months I'm in love with it
I'm gonna have an affair I have to talk
to my wife about this toothbrush and
that's why I love quip and why they're
backed by over 20,000 dental
professionals that's like three grand
per stake right now five hundred I don't
[ __ ] quip starts with just 25 bucks
and you'll and if you go to get quipped
calm slash bread right now you get your
first refill pack for free with a quip
electric toothbrush that's your first
refill pack at GE t qu i p.com slash
burn jesus how many reads out if oh it's
Dollar Shave Club everybody Dollar Shave
Club everything has everything you need
to look feel and smell your best and
they never and you never have to go to
the store that's because they deliver
everything right to your front door and
they keep you fully stocked and what you
use so you don't run out here's how it
works Dollar Shave Club has everything
you need to get ready no matter what
you're getting ready for a date a
graduation murdering your next-door
neighbor they have you covered head to
toe for your hair skin and your face you
name it they have it and they have this
new program where they automatically
keep you stocked up on products use you
determine what you want when you want it
it shows up right at your front door you
fete [ __ ] from once a month to once
every six months plus they're handsome
discount with their handsome discount
the more you buy the more you save it
right now adult shave club has a bunch
of starter sets you can just try for
five bucks like their oral care kit
ladies and after that the the restock
box ships regular size products at
regular prices get your status set for
just five dollars now it's all shave
club calm / / that's dollarshaveclub.com
/ / alright lastly but not leastly
LegalZoom five things business owners
can count on from Legal Zoom number one
uno ah reliability over two million
people have used Legal Zoom to start
their businesses LLC's s corpse
nonprofits DBAs and Mors and Mors and
more you can use Legal Zoom to get
started right away numero dos the
Tolu experience they have been helping
all types of businesses for over 17
years you can count on Lu LegalZoom to
help with all the details number three
tois trace helps I can't do all the way
up to [ __ ] five can I helpful support
they have the right people standing by
ready for your questions all based on in
the US number four cuatro
I'm Tyson legal advice legally isn't a
love firm but they have a network of
independent attorneys licensed in all 50
states sang along they can review
contracts contracts help with employment
laws and advise you on many of the
hurdles that pop up when you're running
a business and finally number five uno
dos tres cuatro Cinco
don't dwell sank no surprises LegalZoom
provides complete transparency with
upfront pricing customer reviews and a
satisfaction guarantee
check out Legal Zoom today to see if
they can make life better for you and
your business and don't forget enter
burnt at checkout be you are are to save
even more LegalZoom where life meets
legal legalzoom.com
[Music]
you
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the Monday morning podcast for
Monday the [ __ ] is it March 28th 2011 oh
my god how its March already over in
like a lamb out like a lion did the
[ __ ] goat see its shadow that's one
of the great things about living in a
desert you don't have to listen to that
dumb [ __ ] when it comes to February and
March you know when you live in the
desert the desert area I don't have to
deal with that [ __ ] what do you think is
gonna happen it's been so mild in the
beginning of March does that mean it's
gonna get temp temp duis towards the end
I don't know they are sharing I don't
know what's gonna [ __ ] happen all I
know is that it's gonna be 70 degrees
out every day for the rest of my life
provided I stay out here um speaking of
the desert I actually visited a friend
of mine visited it-it-it a friend of
mine out in the desert her buddy mine
just had a baby girl well he didn't have
it his wife had it douche um sorry it's
an old joke sorry I'm getting settled in
here I'm getting settled in let me get
settled into the podcast before you
start rolling your [ __ ] eyes at me
and your goddamn cubicle all right
little miss ooh I'm gonna get an office
someday is that what you think that BEC
that cubicle represents look it they
already gave me half the walls and no
ceiling I mean where else can you go
from here someday I'll have a door I got
news for you all right if you're in a
cubicle right now why don't you [ __ ]
grow a dick that includes the legs get
some [ __ ] balls all right take out a
quarter and why don't you stick it in
those plastic bolts that are holding the
walls of your cubicle up all right I'm
not saying take your [ __ ] cubicle
down why don't you just loosen them up
add a little chaos to the day so next
time your boss comes over like that
douche in that movie
office going yeah I'm gonna need you to
yeah when he leans on that [ __ ] maybe
he'll fall backwards and smack his head
off that all-weather carpet you know
that has a very thin layer of padding
and then it's concrete then you could
act like you're concerned I don't know
what happened
and as people sit there you know
freaking out because the guys eating his
tongue at that point in the middle of a
[ __ ] seizure you just you know subtly
retighten the bolts so then it looks
like hey maybe this you know there's no
evidence of why this guy just fell over
maybe he has health problems
at which point his health insurance
they're gonna [ __ ] drop him he'll
then be seen as unstable by the company
and guess what
his [ __ ] office is gonna open up
alright that's how you get a [ __ ]
office nowadays in corporate America
okay you think you're gonna sit there
with your nose to the [ __ ]
Spreadsheets you know doing all that
actuary Horse yet trying to figure out
how long the average person's prostate I
don't [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] you guys do
out there if you live in Nebraska
you're 400 feet from a [ __ ] cornfield
you have an average lifespan of sixty
seven point eight years nobody cares you
know she amazes me about that [ __ ]
that's somebody's passion like just
sitting like the way I love comedy you
know the way a serial killer loves
murder there's somebody out there
sitting in a cubicle just looking at
figures and just seriously has a song in
their heart you know a little bit of
Christmas in their eyes as they try to
figure out how long the average person
in Japan is gonna live now that there's
radioactivity in the ocean you know they
want to get there first to predict the
the death day of somebody over there
I got admit to that [ __ ] that's going on
over there in Japan I told you about
that last week but that's just [ __ ]
freaking me out those poor people over
there you know and I'm telling you I
considering I don't go to the Catholic
Church anymore I am gonna start going to
the church a [ __ ] Ted Nugent
not gonna start referring to myself his
Uncle Bill and feel like as though I'm
rebelling against something but I
definitely I definitely think I need to
secure my perimeter do you know my girl
won't let me get a [ __ ] water bubbler
water bubbler not when a water cooler
she just won't let me do it she's she's
such a [ __ ] broad I'm sitting there
we're watching the disaster unfolding
over there in Japan go and look at these
poor people they live on a fault line
just like us look at the panic and
[ __ ] confusion when you take the
average person who doesn't know how to
live outside and you force them to live
outside they're walking around you know
without a laptop and a cell phone
probably for the first time I'd say in
15 years but that's more American we're
talking Japan here probably for the
first time in 30 years over there you
know with their [ __ ] advancements and
it's just like I'm looking at them like
okay no first thing you [ __ ] want
yeah you want some water
we can go 30 30 days without food right
but water you can only go three days so
here I am going you know we got a couple
of [ __ ] you know gallon jugs of
Arrowhead and that's not an
advertisement there's no advertisement
on this podcast yet okay but I am subtly
throwing it out there to Arrowhead let
me just start mentioning products on my
podcast you know I'm sitting here in my
craftmatic adjustable bed dude he's
totally whoring himself out the [ __ ]
podcast sucks now Wow [ __ ] put you
you put your [ __ ] head down in your
plastic desk right now all right right
there [ __ ] staples shut your face
anyways so we got a we got like two
gallons of [ __ ] water in our
refrigerator and that's it okay those
coolers man you got you got five gallon
jugs so you get two of those you always
have about you know roughly at least
five gallons of water anywhere all the
way up to like seven to nine who the
[ __ ] knows right or maybe you get lucky
the earthquake hits when you got two
full ones
and then when everybody around you is
dying a [ __ ] thirst and you're sitting
in there sipping your water you know
sipping your water running your hands
through your gold coins with your
[ __ ] 9-millimeter between your
[ __ ] legs you're gonna you're gonna
feel okay see that's how Americans look
at a disaster it's not let's all get
together and try to fight through this I
told you last week it's gangs in New
York over here all right
English people before you get on your
[ __ ] high horse if there was a
[ __ ] giant earthquake that affected
all of Europe you're gonna tell you're
gonna help the French people out you're
gonna help out the Krauts huh
all those guys there with their wooden
shoes over there and Holland [ __ ]
tap-dancing along with a [ __ ] cow or
some [ __ ] whatever they do over there
smoking weed you're not gonna help out
you're not all right
so shut your faces anyways so this is
what I'm talking about I'm talking about
preparing yourself for a [ __ ]
disaster all right and what is my girl
concerned about I just don't know where
we're gonna put it it's just you need to
measure it first we can't put it over
there the doggy dish is there the doggy
dish is gonna float out the [ __ ]
window
you know no wait we're up on the second
floor and in the hill we're on in the
hill on a hill right we're gonna be fine
I'm further enough away from the [ __ ]
ocean
I'll tell if the tsunami hits me where
the [ __ ] I'm at I don't want to live you
know what I mean Kevin Costner the real
Kevin Costner not even him playing his
character in Waterworld though real
Kevin Costner will probably float out of
the Hollywood Hills right past me that's
when I take out my 9-millimeter and I
[ __ ] aim it right at his receding
hairline you know I should [ __ ] talk
right and I just [ __ ] blow his brains
out and I take his little raft you know
there's gonna be some half-dressed hot
hot little [ __ ] on the on the raft too
right can't have a [ __ ] disaster
movie unless there's a scantily clad
[ __ ] in the middle of it
so anyways yeah that's what the [ __ ]
she's all about that's what the [ __ ]
she's all about she doesn't know where
we're gonna put it and I'm sitting there
going well you know I could break down
some of the [ __ ] in my office and she's
just like water poplar water cooler in
an office that just you know I was
watching that fat [ __ ] who went to jail
for the stock [ __ ] the other day I can
never remember her name and what is it
Mandy he's got that goddamn bowl cut I
know I know this one I'm gonna scream it
I'm gonna tell you right now later on
the podcast when I'm not thinking about
it I'm gonna remember it I can't [ __ ] it
I keep thinking Rhonda Shear I know it's
not that what is it what was the name of
the chick who [ __ ] shows you how to
make a pie but for some reason doesn't
do it she goes this is how you make the
perfect pumpkin pie and then she calls
in some immigrant to do it for or in a
cooking show how I keep having it was he
thinking Madeleine she's that [ __ ]
chick from Connecticut self-made woman I
respect her you know I feel bad for her
she was the Oswald of Wall Street she
was the Patsy she's the one who went
down they didn't get any of the bankers
they just got her right I think she gets
her pubes highlighted do you think she
has that kind of money Martha Stewart
BAM
I got it you know you'll be having some
money when you get your pubes on baby
y'all ready next for this next
[ __ ] coming to the stage is my
[ __ ] of representing day sir um sorry
had a flashback to some old shows um
anyways hey speaking of survival okay I
Drive a Prius hi you know you know I
love about the Prius is it's not the
gayest car on the road anymore because
Nissan has come out with an all-electric
car called the leaf okay
I challenge you to come up with a gayer
name for a car all right and I'm not
attacking the [ __ ] homosexuals over
there all right as far as I can tell
there's a lot of gay guys that could
kick the living [ __ ] out of me and have
their way with me so the last thing I
want to do is make someone mad at me who
oddly may want to [ __ ] me
[Music]
I'm just saying it's gay as in it's
[ __ ] lame okay
and all you [ __ ] gay people can go
[ __ ] yourselves all right
that's what words do they morph into
other [ __ ] gay used to main mean really
happy the gay 90's the 1890s were known
as the gay 90's that didn't mean there
was a bunch of guys out there blowing
each other right just men everyone was
happy they were happy and gay doesn't
the gay in that old anxiety on the new
year song they all acquaintance be
forgotten hey let's all be gay right
something like that one of those [ __ ]
songs was it in the birthday song the
word gay isn't something I don't know
what it is it's a song that I hear like
once a year and I'm like at it's funny
that gay used to mean happy now it means
you want to dive on your girlfriend's
muff whilst you have a muff yourself you
know isn't that kind of just greedy you
know it's sort of the biggest loser of
sexuality to be gay you know I have a
dick oh I can't get ones not enough
you're selfish [ __ ] you gotta go I have
another one Jesus Christ he's [ __ ]
gluttonous gay people see this why do
the punk I try to do a [ __ ] podcast
last night and it sucked I need a good
night's sleep before I do a podcast cuz
I was driving out from the dancing
because my buddy had a you know his wife
had a baby
beautiful beautiful [ __ ] baby girl is
it isn't such a relief when you show up
in the baby's gorgeous isn't it's such a
[ __ ] relief you know cuz some of them
when they come out obviously they're
like a little bit early or they're a
little weird-looking their [ __ ] head
hasn't fused together yet right and they
look like they look like an octopus some
of them if you chopped off four of its
arms actually six of its arms and then
you put two legs in place of the two
arms alright bill we get it we can do
basic math yeah you know it's got those
little octopus heads and you got to sit
there
yeah well a is the only way you can
stick it back in for a couple of weeks
you know a lot of things you've attacked
on your podcast I draw the line at
babies do you why do you draw the line
at babies huh because you can feel it
kicking in your womb I am really just
being crass on this one who gives a [ __ ]
how far into this podcast are we about
13 minutes halfway through the first
period over halfway speaking about that
you guys see the Bruins Bruins made the
UH just clinched a playoff berth by
finally beating the flies every time I
watch a Bruins Flyers game they lose
unless it's a playoff series then they
just win the first three and then lose
the next [ __ ] four but I so first time
I watch the Bruins Flyers game in a long
time and they actually won
it's a goddamn good team the Flyers have
and the [ __ ] Rangers scare the [ __ ]
out of me with Henrik Lundqvist
[ __ ] stop and everything but I
think Tim Thomas is a better goalie and
I think well you know something we've
oddly adjusted very well once we traded
old doucheface there and he does have a
douche face phil kessel you guys watched
on the NHL Network where for some reason
when they say NHL hockey they have to
tap the guy's do these stupid dramatic
like they'll they're not facing the
camera and then they turn around and
they're all sweaty and they had this
look on their face not happy not sad
just sort of staring intensely it's like
I get it it's hockey it's an intense
sport you know the guy couldn't towel
off before this is he sweating from
being under the lights am I really
supposed to believe that he just skated
over to the bench and you were able to
black out the entire arena and now he's
staring at you well some of them look
cool some of them look intimidating some
of them look okay but phil kessel he
just looks like a douche bag i don't
understand it because he's a [ __ ]
great player but you see his puffy baby
fat cheeks when he turns around and he
just looks like the kid that you would
cross check even if his [ __ ] parents
were standing on the side you know if
you playing like street hockey then you
try to play it up oh I'm sorry
and as he cried it would make you have a
nice feeling
right in your heart you know I'm the
only psycho like that wasn't there
always one kid in your neighborhood you
just love to see cry you know and was
there anything better that when somebody
else did it
and you didn't do it so you could
actually sit there and laugh and enjoy
the kid crying and he didn't have to run
away when his parents came running out
of the house does that scenario even
exist anymore with you [ __ ] this new
generation of [ __ ] [ __ ] out there
who spent their entire childhood
inside on the internet and playing
[ __ ] video games you missed out he
missed out back in the day when you used
to play outside there was always one kid
and he was fat or he was [ __ ] weird
looking so what you did was you picked
on him unless he was funny he realized
okay I gotta be funny you know kind of
like meek when I was a kid I look like
Opie with a little bit of Ralph Malph
and I realized I realized it I'm like
wow I'm the only one who has this
[ __ ] hair color in my neighborhood I
look like a [ __ ] freak I bet I better
start [ __ ] coming with the jokes here
I did that's what I did I said go
outside in a little tuxedo and I would
just start hey interesting happen thing
happened to me a middle of getting
potty-trained or whatever I would I
would have jokes because yeah I used to
get the [ __ ] kicked out of me what do
you think that kick a ginger day is
something new I think we always haven't
been picked on um anyway so what the
[ __ ] am I talking about here oh that's
something that I get I've gotten a lot
lately from people people think I don't
understand the internet which i think is
absolutely hilarious like there's
something to get it kind it is what it
is you know what I mean it's like how
don't I get it cuz I call you out when
you do dumb [ __ ] you know I was on the
Joe Rogan podcast this past week and
[ __ ] amazing podcast I go there and
Joe's like do you know whatever time you
want to come over but blah blah blah
blah blah and I said all right why don't
we say 12:00 noon because I don't want
to get stuck in rush hours basically how
it works out here in LA is you got a
schedule everything between
between 10:00 and 2:00 in the afternoon
any time I have a meeting when do you
want to meet between 10:00 and 2:00
alright buddy of mine al Madrigal
hilarious comedian definitely check him
out al Madrigal he's the one who T told
me to do that so I go 10:00 between
10:00 and 2:00 now I'm not gonna go
there at 10:00 in the [ __ ] morning I
said alright I'll go there 12:00 noon so
I'll do 12:00 noon I'll get out of there
to 2:30 I'll avoid rush hour traffic
right and his [ __ ] podcast is so much
fun I think we did like a three and a
half for our [ __ ] podcast you know
took us like a half an hour to settle in
so he started at 12:30 you know he gave
me this coconut water that was so
[ __ ] delicious I actually came home
and immediately went on to Amazon and
ordered a [ __ ] case of it 12-pack is
what I got you know alligator arm did
not cuz I didn't want to get a case I
just wouldn't want to deal with my
girlfriend going first a water cooler
and now a case of coconut water where
are we gonna put the cereal I didn't
want to deal with that so I only got the
[ __ ] 12-pack alright so anyways we
start the podcast and we just have a
great time [ __ ] went through the
whole thing I definitely suggest you
listen to it I of course don't have the
link cuz I'm an [ __ ] but just look up
Joe Rogan podcast
he gets like 250,000 hits a week so
you'll definitely be able to hear it but
in the end of the podcast I got in this
huge [ __ ] argument with his with his
male assistant tech guy whatever the
[ __ ] you call him the guy who sits there
and you know is constantly adjusting
knobs on the mixer we got a stupid
[ __ ] argument about whether or not
someone had the right to take my podcast
put it on a website that had advertising
on it and I basically said they didn't
you could you know I put my podcast out
there it is free but it's still my
intellectual property I give it away for
free so you take it for free you can't
take it and then start making money off
it and there was a website that was had
all these podcasts and they were you
know they got them all on one website
hence a ton of people went
the website why because of the creation
of the artists their intellectual
property was getting hits no one was
going to the website to look at the
[ __ ] website with nothing on it they
were going there to listen to the
podcast and on their homepage they had
advertising
so all these podcasts were getting
eyeballs to go to the [ __ ] website
alright and they go there and they read
advertising and that's how you sell
advertising by the amount of [ __ ]
people you get to your website so how
you supposed to do that he's supposed to
contact the artists or the owner of the
work and say listen we want to use this
[ __ ] we're gonna be selling advertising
alright we'll take our cut you take your
cut that's fine that's what the [ __ ] you
supposed to do you can't just take it
and put it on your site and start making
money off of it and for some reason he
was saying it was my fault because
technology existed for them to do that
hilarious he completely ignored all the
laws of intellectual property copyright
laws [ __ ] all that you know it's like
you know if you steal somebody's car
that's Grand Theft Auto but if you go
out and you go by wonder what do they
call those those little Jimmy things
those slim jims we can unlock the door
to your car you know if you have one of
those then you know it's not stealing
it's the dumbest it was a stupidest
[ __ ] argument I've ever gotten into
in my life I'm arguing what the actual
law is and this guy is talking about
technology but technology exists for me
to do something illegal therefore it's
not illegal was [ __ ] [ __ ] and the
only thing more [ __ ] was the fact
that I couldn't [ __ ] tap out of the
argument I can't believe I never brought
up well dude I actually called my lawyer
who went to law school in majors in it
with a focus in entertainment law and
not only did he tell me I was 100
percent right
he actually said I could sue that
website if I wanted to which I'm not
going to but that's how right I was
jesus [ __ ] christ I mean a laptop
exists that's legal to buy in a laptop
and with the technology of a laptop and
a little bit of smarts I can break into
your online bank account take all your
[ __ ] money does it mean it's
it's not illegal because laptops are
legal I don't it was a dumbest [ __ ]
argument ever and it lasted for 45
minutes and of course it got a zillion
hits Joe is telling me it got the most
[ __ ] responses alright and you're
gonna sit there and tell me I don't get
the Internet I get it I get it
people like arguments they like
arguments and they like stealing [ __ ]
and not getting you know and not [ __ ]
paying for stuff and then acting like
they don't understand what you're
talking about goes right back to that
all that stealing music that everybody
did remember that [ __ ] then all the
artists got mad going you stealing our
music and every sake we're not stealing
it man we're sharing files no we were
stealing it look what we did we
destroyed and I say we because I was
online why I was on LimeWire for a good
eight months before someone finally was
just like dude we're stealing music how
can we do that then that someone can
steal your [ __ ] comedy this is
[ __ ] I know a lot of you right now
sitting there go whoo there you go you
stole music gift for someone ought to be
able to steal your [ __ ] podcasts and
[ __ ] avid now two wrongs don't make a
right
okay just cuz I go out and murder
somebody doesn't mean someone can come
over and murder somebody I know
we're both gonna get charged with murder
all right I didn't say I was a perfect
person in this people I think it shows
what a big person I am that I commit to
somebody Ron doings in the past but
anyways after [ __ ] 10 years of
stealing music look look at the music
business okay it's over it's [ __ ]
over Steven Tyler is on on American Idol
talking to people who work at a [ __ ]
Cinnabon telling them that they have
good voices and that they have they're
gonna have some sort of career in a
[ __ ] art that where the whole
business model has been completely
[ __ ] destroyed you guys haven't
noticed that [ __ ] musicians are like in
movies now they're doing everything but
singing I saw there's that there's a new
show out where Christina Aguilera is a
judge the lead singer of maroon 5 is a
judge some country singers a judge all
these
guys who cook who used to be able to
sell out the Staples Center it's the
whole [ __ ] thing it's over
so uh I don't know did that even make
sense I didn't know what the [ __ ] my
point was I can't sell it the Staples
Center
all right go [ __ ] yourselves but I was
right in that argument and I actually I
had a great time this week because I
didn't read one of the emails that was
sent to me about that stupid argument I
would just see it Joe Rogan's podcast
RSS feed any of that [ __ ] I just deleted
all of them and it was [ __ ] was
fantastic absolutely fantastic so I
didn't have to read them and argue with
strangers who don't understand the laws
so there you go I hope as some of that
may you know I realize halfway through
that is none of you most you probably
didn't even hear the [ __ ] argument
but you'll probably go to Joe Rogan's
podcast to listen to it won't you see
that look at me spread in the podcast
love alright with that with that running
of the [ __ ] mouth what do I have
coming up here people this week I'm
actually gonna be what am I gonna be I'm
in town this week I'm actually working
on April 2nd I let me get the exact date
here in case I screw this up the name of
the show it's Kevin and beans
April foolishness show they do it at the
Gibson Amphitheatre I did it last year
and had yeah April 2nd I had an
unbelievably great time and absolutely
loved doing doing this gig because not
only do I get to work with a bunch of
comedians that I never get to see
anymore it's all a bunch of headliners
bunt as far as the [ __ ] and I can see of
course I don't have any of the [ __ ]
names who the hell's on a Patton
Oswalt's on it Jimmy Kimmel's on it I'm
on it
Kevin of beans I forget I can't remember
the lineup is [ __ ] real I think Dana
Gould might be on it I shouldn't name
names here because I don't know it's
gonna be awesome all these guys that I
love watching at work are gonna be on it
and and on top of that the Kip C Gipson
am p theater is used to be called the
universal Lampe theatre and that's the
one where the Blues Brothers they when
they recorded briefcase full of Blues
with my favorite through one of my
favorite drummers of all time
Steve Jordan that's where they did it
right there on that stage and they were
opening for Steve Martin back when he
wore the white suit with the [ __ ]
arrow through his head I'm a geek for
that type of [ __ ] theater history I
always try to find out I mean I sit
there really Charlie Chaplin play played
here Buster Keaton like that dumb [ __ ]
you know so anyways I'll be doing that
on April 2nd and then what else do I got
oh I'm gonna be in Maryland at the
record theater for two shows on April
8th and then I'm gonna be at the Tower
Theatre in Philadelphia Pennsylvania on
April 9th and then later on that month
I'm hitting two cities I haven't done
stand-up ever or in a long time
Milwaukee never been there gonna be at
the the Pabst Theater in Milwaukee
Wisconsin April 22nd on April 23rd I'll
be at the Royal Oak Music Theatre in
Detroit Michigan I have not been there
since I did the Chappelle show tour with
Charlie Murphy and Donnell Rawlings and
I think we did that we did that one back
in 2004 so it's been seven years since
I've been there so so please come out to
that and with that let's get on with the
podcast questions for the week where is
it Alton I'm not even open the [ __ ]
thing Jesus Christ bill you call
yourself a radio host or a podcast host
is that is that what you call me is that
what you call yourself bill alright open
[ __ ]
what can I talk about here what can I
talk about can I talk about how the
Bruins raped the Montreal Canadiens
seven to nothing did you guys see that
[ __ ] game
absolutely raped him and I got to tell
you they deserved every [ __ ] second
of that because they're still bitching
about that Zdeno Chara hit you know he
finished his [ __ ] check the problem
was is that they still have that [ __ ]
board that piece of glass right there
that's the problem the problem is the
NHL have seen for years guys almost get
their [ __ ] heads taken off on that
part of the ice what you should do is
just somehow make that thing collapsible
move it away from the ice I don't know
what the
to do but this gotta be okay if I can
have a car that has a collapsible
front-end and the engine is designed to
go underneath me rather into than into
my [ __ ] torso there's no way the NHL
can't have that I'll put the clip on
there by the way on the MM podcast.com
so you guys can see see that hit I mean
it was brutal because the guy fractured
one of his vertebrae and so I felt bad
about that but then they were talking
about the severity of the guy's
concussion and it turns out the [ __ ]
douche went to the movies like three
days later with this allegedly severe
concussion gotta love Mark Recchi for
calling him out he was actually taking
heat off shower just saying yeah you
know I think he exaggerated it how
awesome is that he did that you know
already knowing how [ __ ] sensitive
they are up there they're so [ __ ]
sensitive up there in Montreal it's not
like Toronto Toronto is a fun goddamn
city Montreal some of the most beautiful
women you ever gonna see in your life
but the men are just so [ __ ]
sensitive they actually have the police
looking into that hit somebody think
about somebody got checked into the
[ __ ] boards okay and unfortunately
right where the glass starts you know or
the glass in between the benches you
know and that they want to like put one
of the Bruins in jail for playing hockey
you know I'll tell what's funny is 10
years ago there wouldn't even been a
penalty on that play anyways so this is
the deal um the new email if you want to
send me an email if you want to send me
more [ __ ] emails about agreeing or
disagreeing with my argument on Joe
Rogan you sent it to bill at the mmm
podcast calm please send me your
underrated overrated lists your advice
if you have any questions your stories
of revenge you know all the [ __ ] that
we've been doing throughout the years
here and now speaking of overrated
underrated I got one here for you as far
as something being overrated you know
what's overrated is outlets you know you
know when the broads get all excited
what go into the outlets they got an
they got a [ __ ] what the hell did
they shop at they got a Jordan Marsh at
JCPenney
in a Filene's outlet did any of those
stores still exist or did Macy's just
[ __ ] buy up all of them you know
whatever whatever the [ __ ] they buy you
know they got all those stores oh my god
it's gonna be blah blah blah so you
going there is a guy going alright well
maybe this won't cost me as much [ __ ]
money what do you want a pair of shoes
sweetie hey let's go to the outlet
sounds like a [ __ ] you know sounds
like a dream because when you really
think about it it doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense why is it so goddamn cheap
why did they suddenly decide that they
just didn't want to make as much money
on that shirt that that seven-year-old
sewed together in the Philippines as
they would in a mall what is it about
the outlet you know if you use common
sense you'd actually think well they're
probably not marking them down as much
as they think they as they say they are
and it's probably a bunch of [ __ ] that
nobody wanted a bunch of [ __ ] that
didn't sell well at the malls and now
they got to get [ __ ] rid of it isn't
that what it is that's been my
experience you go to they're overrated
you go to an outlet and another thing
that they like doing is they like to say
that the the actual retail price is
about 30% more than it usually is and
then they give you a 2% discount and you
feel like you're getting like 32 percent
off you know cuz people suck at math
they'll do
adidas shell-toes usually a hundred and
twenty six dollars now only 68 you know
what a [ __ ] are they you know 168 or
whatever hun
whatever the [ __ ] number I just said
this she'll toast there's no arch
support whatsoever it's the same [ __ ]
design that you've had for the last 40
[ __ ] years so there's no there's no
extra cost
you know if to hire somebody to design a
new [ __ ] sneaker alright it's like a
goddamn Porsche it's the same [ __ ]
design forever
so whatever so we go there and she goes
in she goes into Prada and I walk in
it's still a [ __ ] ridiculously
expensive shoe I got so [ __ ] mad in
my girl at that thing I was telling to
saying listen listen we're going out to
the desert my buddy had a kid it's his
first kid I want to go out there we that
that's that's what it's supposed to be
about she know [ __ ] women they can't
just go out and go do they always got to
get something yeah if you notice said
all you young studs out there banging
away having one even if you have a
one-night stand with them they still try
to get a t-shirt out of it even notice
that can you feel you teach it then they
just walk out with it [ __ ] weird
they're like they're like serial killers
like they're taking some sort of a
trophy making a goddamn voodoo doll Kim
Kim you know I was one that was one of
the one of the turning points as me as a
single guy when I asked for the t-shirt
back I started doing it could have my
t-shirt back and I loved it because they
didn't know what to cuz they were pissed
that they asked for it that I asked for
it but then they also didn't want to
come off as some selfish [ __ ] so then
they had to take it off but out there
just uh
the conflicting emotions on their face
mad that you asked and then trying to
play it off like they're not mad so you
can see that they're actually a good
girl who will jump on your dick after
knowing you for about four and a half
hours right so anyways overrated outlets
all right they [ __ ] overrated unless
there's a bunch of stores that you like
then it's just convenient that's the
best you're gonna get you know it's
convenient well at least I don't have to
walk through a food court in two levels
I like that it's just one level I do
like that aspect of it but in general I
don't see the [ __ ] deals it's like
how you know do you know how like Vegas
used to be mob run and now it's
corporate corporate owned and gradually
the the $8 steak disappeared that you
could get dude you can get a steak for
like six bucks you can anymore
they turned them all into Buffett the
buffets it's like the twenty dollar
buffet and then you got to go there and
feel like you know you ate your money's
worth so you go there and eat ten times
more than you normally would have and
then you [ __ ] you killing yourself you
you ever eat so much you start sweating
you just have such a bizarre combination
you
like rice and then a slice of cake some
[ __ ] pancakes and then a piece of
fish you know your body's just like dude
what the [ __ ] and you finish it off with
like a pickle then he just sitting there
right looking like that guy on man vs.
food you know when he gets down to the
final two bites and he goes into what I
call the thinker pose you know where
he's got his fist up against his skull
[Laughter]
yeah it's the same thing
outlets that's it's it's the same hype
that people used to say about Vegas
people finally have stop saying the $6
steak [ __ ] all right so there you go
that's overrated underrated for the week
please keep sending those in people I
love I love reading those things um all
right advice for this week these are I'm
becoming just sort of the relationship
advice person I don't know how this has
happened considering I've I've never
been married I don't have any kids you
know so I don't know you know I'm
basically the Steve de Burgh of
relationships you know I'm somehow still
in the league still in the game
pulled in the clipboard but I haven't
taken a [ __ ] snap in like nine years
that's what I am I'm standing on the
sidelines is all you guys are getting
married and having kids just sitting
here [ __ ] wearing a headset all right
but you guys want advice here we go here
we go
okay so I've been together with my girl
for almost four years got married last
September in 2010 these past weeks have
been hell I'm a very honest person so I
felt lately that me and my wife have not
been close so I talked to my wife and
told her how I felt
you know and if we continue like this
things can end up in divorce not things
will he stress can all capital can end
up in divorce
so we talked it over and all seemed okay
Sunday the 28th I asked her when she was
coming home this was a 10:20 p.m. she
told me in the next 20 minutes I said
okay cool I'll see you at home I was
driving home from her father city so it
took me longer to get home I get home at
12:00 a.m. and she is still not home so
I call her and say please tell me if
you're not gonna come home on time so I
so I know you're okay
alright sounds like a decent guy what
does she do she starts yelling at him
saying uh I lost my place she starts
yelling at me saying I was helping my
damn friend stop being an [ __ ] then
she hung up
Wow she got home and yelled at me and
everything and we argued she went to bed
mad at me and I slept on the couch first
time I've ever done that in our
relationship that's par for the course
you got married in September you go
through the honeymoon phase right
through the holidays and all of a sudden
Valentine's Day comes up that's more
excitement now you were into March March
is the real deal okay if you can get
along in March that that's that's a good
benchmark you know there's nothing going
on in March there's no Valentine's Day
there's no holidays unless she has a
birthday then it doesn't count hey Bill
why don't you shut the [ __ ] up and read
the rest of the email all right all
right I will
all right next morning she leaves to
work and I tell her I hope you hope you
know me sleeping on the couch is not a
good thing and she goes well me not
kissing you before I leave isn't a good
thing either Jesus later on Monday she
says I am not sleeping at home tonight I
don't know if I want to be with you
anymore Jesus Christ dude this is like
[ __ ] going vertical here she's in the
Space Shuttle um
it's Friday now and all week she hasn't
come home to me she won't even tell me
where she is sleeping barely answers my
text and/or calls she told me she isn't
happy I don't treat her good she doesn't
love me the way she used to but not once
did she sit me down like a civil person
and tell me to change she just up she up
and just left bill please tell me if you
love someone and you're married would it
be easy to just up and leave like that
leave that person with no warning and
not giving the person a chance unless
she has another secret Oh gah I think
he's suggesting that she might have
another guy she's filing for divorce
soon told me to keep everything she just
wants her vehicle on
dying inside and had been going crazy I
cannot believe she would put me through
this she said she's been thinking of
this for two months but never sat me
down so I can work on being a better man
while do two months is a long time when
you only been married since September
that's basically 20 percent of your
marriage I would think so anyways he
goes on to say she had nothing when we
met I drove her to school every day and
her parents did not care for her I did
everything for her why would she screw
me like this alright so what advice do
you want here you want me to know why
she would do this alright let's let's
alright I'd have everything she said
there I know all my listeners right now
are pretty much convinced that she's out
[ __ ] around on you and you know who's
kidding hope they definitely I don't
think would be wrong to think that but I
think the fly in the ointment here is
your description of her relationship
with their parents when you said that
you drove her to school and did
everything for her yet her parents did
not care for her this is something that
I noticed in my horrific dating past if
you want to get somebody stable you have
to come up with some sort of list of
qualifications that they have to pass or
at least they have to pass most of them
and one of the things if you want to get
a well-adjusted female I'm not saying
that they can't come from divorce but
they have to have a good relationship
with their parents okay I found that to
be a major red flag if I was on a date
and I found out that the person I was on
a date with was not speaking to either
their mother or their father or would
say my dad's a piece of [ __ ] or I
[ __ ] hate my mother or we don't talk
right there I'm telling you just run in
the other direction because I don't know
it just seeps into your [ __ ]
relationship and they do [ __ ] like this
because I'm thinking if you were doing
everything if she came from a household
where her parents people who are
supposed to love her unconditionally and
they weren't doing [ __ ] for her and then
you
in there and you start doing everything
for her just just out of never having
that in her life on some level she's
gonna fall in love with you even if she
doesn't love you she loves you because
you're giving her what her parents never
gave gave her gave her you know what I
mean
but that doesn't mean that she loves you
and I think that that's and then you
combine the fact that she had a [ __ ]
up relationship with the parents where
there was no love and that type of stuff
she doesn't know what love is and can't
communicate and when she's not feeling
it she doesn't know how to get out of it
like a [ __ ] adult hence she just
leaves you and then because she's been
searching for life love her entire
[ __ ] life
rather than just going out on her
[ __ ] own and just being alone and
figuring out what she wants it kind of
seems like she already has another guy
and she's just swinging to that dude
going right into another relationship so
I'll tell you this this is what I would
do I would consider myself [ __ ] lucky
that she did it this quick that you
found out that you were married to a
psycho and that she only wants her
[ __ ] car alright so what I would do
is give her her space
don't call her be civil work the [ __ ]
thing out sign the divorce papers let
her get in her [ __ ] VW thing whatever
the [ __ ] she drives and let her and her
baggage drive down to the goddamn street
alright then you [ __ ] I don't know do
the usual [ __ ] go to the gym cry it out
go to the [ __ ] gym alright don't beat
yourself up don't start drinking don't
start becoming a fat [ __ ]
alright turn this [ __ ] around I'm
telling you I don't come up with some
healthy [ __ ] way to deal with this
[ __ ] and don't do the guys [ __ ] will you
[ __ ] white-knuckle your way through
it and in booze and go bang a fat chick
don't do that [ __ ] alright [ __ ] you
know curl up in the fetal position cry
it out and just tell you keep telling
yourself you're gonna meet the right
girl do that but that one right there
dude flush that one down the [ __ ]
toilet and consits a blessing it's a
blessing dude can you imagine if you had
a kid with that [ __ ] nightmare
and for the rest of your [ __ ] life or
at least for the next 18 goddamn years
she's gonna be in your [ __ ] life and
you got to listen to her opinions which
would totally affect on some level your
relationship with the next great girl
that you're gonna meet your next girl is
gonna be a great girl because you've
been through the [ __ ] with this [ __ ]
trust me all right it's gonna hurt
just [ __ ] deal with it all right
platoon take the pain all right okay
that's it next one all right bill being
this girl another another relationship
1b bill me and this girl is stationed
overseas in the military England lucky
enough due to our jobs we see each other
a couple times a week for meetings and
at the gym here are my 47 dilemmas
there's a chance of being deployed and
all of that business due to the war with
yogurt faced in Libya the least of my
worries oh by the way did you see that
[ __ ] there was a couple of was it uh
sure
Beyonce and Mariah Carey actually did
private New Year's gigs from for a
million bucks did New Year's gigs for
Gaddafi's kids can you [ __ ] believe
that
how much [ __ ] money do you need to
make you know you're gonna take a gig
where you gonna go dance
like a goddamn [ __ ] clown for a mass
murderers kids then you take that
[ __ ] blood money stick it in your
bank account go buy yourself some
[ __ ] glitter or whatever the hell you
do when you're a goddamn singer buy some
more streamers to hang on your [ __ ]
mic stand and then when you get busted
you try to play it off like you had no
idea who Qaddafi is and what he's done
yeah you couldn't remember that he
claimed he was behind the PanAm bombings
that killed fellow Americans the [ __ ] is
wrong with you I love that [ __ ] where
they tried to play it off like they had
no idea okay at the low level of
entertainment that I'm at any time I do
a private gig they always tell you what
the deal is
I don't do private gigs anymore because
as Dane Cook classically put you feel
like you're being rented that's the
greatest way
to describe how you feel when you do
that kick see if you're doing it if you
come out to a comedy club or a theater
to see my act you get my act and I get
to say whatever I want but if you hire
me
to perform for your your company or a
private [ __ ] Christmas party or some
[ __ ] like that like I used to do those
gigs there's always a list this is what
they do stay away from this and you
either comply to the list or you just
don't take the gig the last thing you do
is say yeah yeah no no no problem then
you show up and do your Lenny Bruce
[ __ ] set and then walk away thinking
you're a badass you're not a badass
you're just an [ __ ]
you're gonna go in there and curse and
they wanted to clean comic you shouldn't
have taken the gig they're hiring you
private gig right so but anyways anytime
I do a gig if there's somebody in a
[ __ ] wheelchair
if there's somebody mentally handicapped
just that [ __ ] alone they'll poke the
head in the back hey just to let you
know I don't know what jokes you do but
this is the situation out there just
giving you the heads up so there's no
problem there's no [ __ ] way their
agents didn't say hey listen just to let
you know you're performing for the
children of a mass murderer this is how
they feel about females over there stay
away from this you're able to gyrate
this much during songs but there was a
whole [ __ ] it's a million-dollar gig
there's no way the agent lets the
artists go in there not knowing who the
[ __ ] they're performing for with
performing to risking losing their
commissioned on a million-dollar [ __ ]
gig they're completely full of [ __ ]
they're just giving the money back
because they got [ __ ] caught that's
it's I think it's horrific absolutely
horrific so anyways back to the email um
so we've both been here mean this broad
for about six money six months okay let
me recap here up into this point he sees
his girl a couple times a week alright
okay so the two dilemmas he works with
the girl and also if he starts
developing feelings at any point he
could get deployed to Libya and she
couldn't and she might not or they might
both and they'll be in separate parts of
the country not [ __ ] seeing each
other you know what I mean
[ __ ] I don't even say how the [ __ ]
we start a third war we couldn't even
afford one I I really don't understand
it alright let's continue here uh we've
both been here about six months and in
that time everyone on the basis tried to
get into this chicks pants she's a
bombshell for certain no one seems to
get closer I come to find out she's
basically got dumped when she left her
last base stateside and has been cooped
up in her house off base trying to keep
in touch with this dude she's rarely
gone out and hasn't given date dating or
whatever much of a thought as far as I
can wager meanwhile I've been busy being
miserable on my own as well as this as I
had this stint with some [ __ ] cop chick
over the winter and that basically died
about two to three weeks ago I start
talking to this broad and spending time
together regularly after work nothing
too seriously but apparently I can make
her laugh I'm getting the notion that
she's moving on from her old
relationship things seem to be going
swimmingly I'm just not certain I can
take the multiple risk and try to make a
situation out of this that would think
wouldn't somehow end up in some sort of
complete disaster I'm technically
[ __ ] where I eat and it's not like I
can just quit this job tomorrow I'm in
the [ __ ] military I'm trying to avoid
certain disaster yet however I'm primed
to be in the zone for a good good
looking piece and perhaps a healthy
relationship thereafter I'm not sure how
far how far to take this thing I'm
conflicted I could use a laugh thanks
for the podcast all right all right dude
these are very [ __ ] mature concerns
this is all up to you you got to figure
out how you feel about this girl all
right and then act accordingly all right
if you want to [ __ ] just bang this
girl if you figure that out if you just
want to bang this girl just be up front
and tell her that it's just a sex thing
and she that goes for it or she doesn't
all right and if she goes for it and you
bang her and then you don't call her
afterwards you know you're just still
not having feelings for her she can't
get mad legitimately because you talked
to her about it up front of course
there's always that you know 18% psycho
rule where she could be thinking well
after he [ __ ] me he's gonna realize
what a great person I am and then we'll
have a relationship you know I would be
a little bit nervous about this girl
because she's still hanging on to this
other person so I don't know if she's
just wounded or if she is an actual
psycho so I will tell you this if you
just have a [ __ ] buddy relationship with
her this is the key all right you have
to space out the times when you bang her
all right and when you bang her she can
never spend the night
you also can't watch a movie with her
you can't do any sort of things that
indicate you have some sort of
relationship beyond [ __ ] all right
and you have to bang her like the filthy
[ __ ] [ __ ] that she is that's
basically how you sustain a fuck-buddy
relationship you [ __ ] you leave
that's all you do we are [ __ ] buddies we
are not movie slash [ __ ] buddies we are
[ __ ] buddies and that is it
all right if she calls you up now ask
you to come over there and help hang a
[ __ ] picture you don't have time you
can't [ __ ] do it all right that's it
you are you are a dick and that's it now
if you want to have a [ __ ]
relationship with her you got to figure
out if you really like this girl
at which point if you're mature enough
you probably shouldn't try and [ __ ] her
because that will cloud everything
personally I've never been able to do
that so good luck to you those are your
two options [ __ ] buddy relationship
figure out what the [ __ ] you want to do
and then act accordingly all right sir
good luck um hey Bill I'm going on my
11th hour of work today but up and up on
can read that part they're too many
names there okay anyways bill I was fat
and in a destructive relationship for
most of college my confidence was just
about ruined before I dumped the [ __ ]
and I lost about 70 pounds good for you
see this guy did the right thing he got
it for that guy with the first question
this guy here he got out of a
relationship all right look what happens
he goes to the gym II dropped 70 pounds
good for you since then I've been with a
lot of women and haven't had trouble
meeting women I just know how to act
confident I have trouble fine but I do
have trouble finding the
between [ __ ] aggressiveness and
simply being confident all right well
you're already banging a bunch of women
you've lost 70 pounds it sounds like
you're killing it so what what happened
did you piss off a couple of women what
is your definition of [ __ ]
aggressiveness are you talking to them
you're like a baby just reach up and
grab a tittie you know this is the thing
about being confident what you got to do
is be confident about yourself but don't
insult the woman don't like I I've never
liked that like some guys do that what
they do is they go up there and how they
how they get the girl to be in a weak
position is they sort of say things to
her that that kind of makes her like
insecure I don't know what is a good
example of that type of stuff like I
know you just make some sort of comment
about the clothes they're wearing or
just something or just be like what is
an example I see I never did that not
because I'm a [ __ ] great guy just
because I haven't need to be liked so I
could never go that way although I have
found that like reacting to other hot
girls walking around the club with a lot
of girls will somehow I don't know it's
this weird thing with it like that's
sort of that competitiveness you know if
you can just get into conversation about
them about you know how hot you think
some other girl is I know this sounds
[ __ ] but this is actually work for me
and then you just start talking about
what you like in women what turns you on
and then you steer the conversation into
sex and then you're in there so I would
say for me the difference between be an
[ __ ] aggressive is if I actually say
something mean I don't know I don't
think you should ever be mean to a girl
to try to get her to [ __ ] you I just
think that's like a cowardly way into it
but you know for you to be a cocky
[ __ ] and if they just that they say
that they compliment you about how you
look just be like a dumb you know I'm a
good-looking guy I don't know what it is
women like me just just along those
[ __ ] lines you just do that
as you're sort of making fun of yourself
then you show you up a sense of humor I
would I would try to go that [ __ ]
route I don't know but once again you're
talking to a guy looks like Ralph Malph
so it probably works you know you guys
maybe you guys can be [ __ ] if you
actually have some sort of pigment in
your hair
all right let's plow ahead here I bill a
friend of mine who I played in the band
with for over a year in high school lost
his mother to a sudden sorry sudden
heart attack at the memorial service I
get out of my dorky hippie Ford Fusion
Hybrid at the church and see a smoking
hot chick climbing out of a white 2010
Ford Mustang GT with racing stripes and
walks inside dude that sounds like the
beginning of a great [ __ ] movie you
know the nerd is a little douchey car
and then some hottie you know was it
Christie Brinkley from those [ __ ]
European vacation movies anyways it was
mysterious and intriguing at the same
time exactly I didn't know too many
people at the funeral and I was the only
guy what I didn't know too many people
here as I only met the guy through my
younger brother and was not super close
with him then what the [ __ ] are you
doing with the funeral at the funeral
Jesus Christ his mother was an artist so
after is after the receiving line there
was a reception with her art displayed
around the room and I was sipping coffee
and looking at some of her art this is a
[ __ ] cool last funeral looking at
some of her art on the wall I glanced to
my right and there she is standing right
next to me I leaned in and I say I like
your car 45 minutes later after learning
she is a nurse at a local hospital and
graduated from I learned that she was a
nurse from a local hospital and
graduated from my high school dude is
this girl like a call girl that sounds
like a [ __ ] call girl she just shows
up in a hot car dressed like a [ __ ]
hottie and she's a fish he wearing the
nurse's outfit anyways he goes on to say
I knew her family a little bit she loves
sports I love sports care I decided to
say goodbye to her and not ask for her
number I mean it's a [ __ ] funeral
dude there's no rules when it comes to
getting laid okay I don't give a [ __ ] if
you're [ __ ] treading water after a
tsunami all right she didn't have time
to put a bra on she's got a t-shirt on
what yeah you're not gonna [ __ ] you
know I can't ask for a number at that
point or [ __ ] cell phones underwater
I guess you know hey you wanna wha form
a two-person circle over here I heard it
keeps the Sharks away sorry anyways blah
blah blah but thanks to Facebook I get I
find a route I find where the [ __ ] she
is her name and she has all these
pictures but she has all these pictures
of her and some chunky kid worse than
the college version of me she also has
some status about a great Valentine's
Day about but nothing about being in a
relationship I know this sounds like
teeny bump [ __ ] but this girl was
amazing we hit it off and I sure don't
want to [ __ ] it up with some awkward
[ __ ] we've exchanged a few emails and
stuff but I don't know how to find out
her deal without just asking I also
don't want to come on too strong and
ruin the friendship fetus by creeping
her out I want to ask her to hurt I want
to ask her to the anti social network
show that you guys are doing with Jim
Norton Jim Breuer and Dave Attell but I
have a real fear of ruining the great
vibe we have with something she might
not be accepting all right do what
you're basically doing by sitting here
being timid is you're getting yourself
into that Chris Rock friend zone you
have to admit you have to make a move
right now you talk to her at the [ __ ]
funeral she talked to you for 45 minutes
out of at a funeral you didn't ask for
the number right there you should have
lost the game but because everybody gets
a ribbon with this generation there's
Facebook so you get to [ __ ] make it
up now she's exchanging emails with you
how many more [ __ ] clues do you need
she has a vague sort of relationship
status on her Facebook ask her to the
[ __ ] show it's perfect all right
you're going to a comedy show we'll make
her laugh
you sit there laughing it up with her
accidentally put her hand on your hand
on a [ __ ] thigh and you're red I know
it's not that easy but dude you need to
ask her out sooner rather than [ __ ]
later and I have a go to a comedy show
that'd be great I think that'd be a
great idea and
that's it all right so ask her out
that's my advice for this [ __ ] week
and I apologize for my horrific reading
let me give you some YouTube videos here
that will all be up on the mmm podcast
calm the official fan website of the
Monday morning podcast we had 7500 hits
last week that's the most we've ever
gotten so I want to thank everybody
who's been going there so here we go
here's the YouTube videos for the
weekend if you don't want to go up and
look at them individually on YouTube you
can look at them all right no neat
little rope on the MM podcast.com
alright for those of you who are into
drugs man
we got a great one about nineteen sixty
one it's a video on mushrooms and I
believe I can't really tell what's going
on here I think they're it's the
beginning of ecstasy I have no idea what
but it's just great listening to the
weird music that they're playing when
they describe what these mushrooms do to
you
Elvis's date-rape blue Hawaii blue
Hawaii trailer there's just a bunch of
clips of Elvis right before he bangs a
lot of chicks and some of the [ __ ] that
he gets away with just being mean and
being really misogynistic and not to
mention what's [ __ ] hilarious
is he doesn't have a shirt on in most of
it because he's on the beach and you
just to see what being in shape looked
like back in the day he has no ABS and
he has these little seventh-grade arms
and a little [ __ ] chest little
chicken chest but basically in [ __ ] in
shape back in the 50s and 60s just meant
you weren't fat I mean you just suck in
your gut a little bit but he is their
most horrific bathing suit I've ever
seen in my life
and I don't know you could basically do
a nine-hour seminar at a feminist
convention if they just showed this
entire just the movie trailer alone this
is a bizarre video is a hidden-camera
British [ __ ] threatens to ruin exes life
this guy's marriage is falling apart and
he's filming it it's just really bizarre
if you like watching something really
[ __ ] awkward just definitely check it
out and oh here's a new one this is what
I call pre 9/11 these YouTube videos we
just see people doing [ __ ]
public that nowadays would end with a
felony and the person on TV scolding
them I know I've showed this video
before but man jumps out of stands and
catches football just in case for the
new podcast listeners on one Monday
Night Football game the Bears versus the
Packers somebody kicked a field goal and
as it's going through the uprights this
guy jumps out of the stands and catches
it I mean you'd get tasered and you'd be
put in jail immediately now and not only
does this guy not get tasered he goes
back to the [ __ ] stands he's allowed
to continue watching the game and Dan
Dierdorf and Al Michaels are just
laughing their [ __ ] asses off think
it's the greatest thing ever and that
just makes me think about I wasn't a
great before 9/11 when you could have a
great time and do [ __ ] like that and was
just considered all innocent fun and it
didn't have to be treated like it was
that it was at a sama bin Laden who just
jumped out of the [ __ ] stands and all
right the next YouTube video this is uh
this is one for John Bonham fans this is
a very rare video or just one I've never
seen its a Paul McCartney video where
it's Paul McCartney and wings and
Friends it's some horrific lie awful
awful song called The Rock astre theme
but they you know one of those things
well they put together like an all-star
cast of people to raise money kind of
like a precursor to the we are the world
thing and they have three drummers -
three drummers and one of them is John
Bonham is not only is he not playing
ludwig's he's playing this drum kit I
don't know if it's a North drum kit or
there was another drum kit out there
called a stingray in the late 70s and
early 80s they had these this radical
design on the drums where they sort of
had the bottom of the drum looks like
it's made if you out we're on acid and
you were looking at a drum kit looks
like it's melted and it's pointed out at
the crowd allegedly at Major Tom sound
better buts the only time I've ever seen
John Bonham not playing one of his
famous Ludwig kits and any of the
drummers out there can you please tell
me what the kit is because I looked it
up on the Internet I tried to find
images of stingray drum kits and I saw a
couple of the
modern ones where they had the warp
Tom's but I couldn't find any of the
classic ones I could look through my old
Modern Drummer ones magazines that I
couldn't find it but if anybody knows
the name of the drumkit I'd love to know
all right and that's it I think that's
it for this uh for this week yeah that's
it a couple of movies somebody says -
movie to avoid battle Los Angeles is it
was like Independence Day took a [ __ ]
all over the Expendables just didn't buy
into it maybe it's because I've been
sober for a while and I saw it with a
few pot heads who loved it to death
wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up during the
movie and kept making stupid comments
like dude we're [ __ ] um yeah I mean
come on who goes to battle Los Angeles
and actually thinks it's gonna be
Chariots of Fire which I actually
thought that movie sucked yeah I think
you need to smoke leave me dead that's
the movie that that movie is for pot
heads that's one you know either eat a
[ __ ] you know a little weed cookie
and go see and have a good time
see that's right there there you go
there's something positive about weed it
makes mu awful movies like battle Los
Angeles enjoyable and like relevant and
somebody said Lincoln Lincoln Lawyer was
awesome alright that's it that is the
podcast for this week you guys all have
a great week thanks for everybody who
listens to the Monday morning podcast if
you want to hear that epic argument that
I had with red band you know and yes we
are friends we got along great actually
did a set at Sal's comedy hole and we
laughed about the arguments so you know
there's no reason to gossip anything
beyond if you just really want to listen
to a great argument of two people who
just don't know how to say agree to
disagree I definitely suggest listen to
it I also definitely recommend
subscribing to Joe Rogan's podcasts it's
[ __ ] awesome I had a great time on it
and that's it that's the podcast for
this week I will see some of you at the
Gibson Amphitheatre on April 2nd for the
Kevin and bean comedy show that raises
money for I forget what cause I know
it's a great cause because no one ever
raises money for terrorists
right I guess unless you do a comedy
show in like Saudi Arabia isn't that
what they do you know that's how they
raise money with their filthy [ __ ]
oil money then they funnel it through
the mosques isn't that how it goes down
is that other paper trail goes down if
you guys leave read Rolling Stone
magazine you got to check it out on
these two potheads who became
international arms dealers it's really
interesting to watch two kids get
involved in that type of [ __ ] and also
to see how that game is run and it also
kind of makes you understand why why
certain countries really do not like
other countries and kind of what's going
on it's just completely [ __ ] so I
definitely recommend checking that out
and I that's it all right can I just
shut the [ __ ] up now I'm gonna shut the
[ __ ] up now all right you guys have a
great week go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll
talk to you later
[Music]
last night